[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer die große
Offensive gegen die Dominanz des Dollars
hat begonnen mal wieder ja alle paar
Jahre wird das Ende des Dollars als
internationale Leitwährung verkündet
seine Ablösung durch den chinesischen
rhein-mainbi bzw und das der saß da das
dies für die US-Wirtschaft bedeuten
würde und dann passiert nichts oft das
genaue Gegenteil aber dieses Mal könnte
vielleicht diesmal alles anders sein
oder vielleicht doch nicht wem soll man
glauben den Propheten einer neuen bricks
Weltordnung oder den Dollar Jüngern oder
abstürzen oder wird er immer stärker
werden klar ist der Dollar ist
spätestens seit dem Brandenburgs
Abkommen von 1944 die Grundlage des
weltweiten Finanz und Handelssystems das
meine lieben Freunde sind fast acht
Jahrzehnte der Dollar Herrschaft über
die Welt diese verschafft den USA
natürlich einen gewaltigen Vorteil wenn
es darum geht Ihre Interessen aber auch
ihre Wertvorstellungen global
durchzusetzen und wisst ihr was genau
deswegen wird gerade
Motoren und autokratischen herrschen von
Schwellenländern der Drang zu
Überwindung der dollar-dominanz immer
größer diese Machthaber beginnt zum
Beispiel die Folgen ihrer enormen
Abhängigkeit von Uncle Sam's Banknoten
zur fürchten manche wegen den möglichen
Sanktionen die ihnen drohen könnten so
haben die Sanktionen gegen Russland und
das Einfrieren der Guthaben der
russischen Zentralbank in den USA und
Europa deutlich gemacht wie stark die
Vermögenswerte von Tyrannen bedroht sind
und dann wären da noch die
Schwellenländer Weise die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen der Politik der
Reserve fürchten sie wurden z.B vom
rasanten Anstieg der sitzsätze zwischen
2022 und 23 eiskalt erwischt und warum
nun weil die Unternehmen in den
Schwellenländern in Dollar hauptsächlich
nutzen um ihre Exportpreise festzulegen
und sich zu finanzieren und wenn die
US-Zinsen steigen oder der Dollar
aufwertet bekommen Sie eine gewaltiges
Problem
[Musik]
das sind also die beiden Hauptgründe
warum die Offensive gegen den Dollar 9
Schwung bekommt zum ersten Mal scheint
es einen klaren politischen Willen zu
geben die Dominanz des Dollars zu
überwinden wir sehen eine allmähliche
Erosion des Dollars es entsteht das Bild
eines multipolaren Währungssystems
Massimiliano Castelli Leiter der
Strategie für globale
staatsanleihenmärkte bei der UBS also
inwieweit ist die Vorherrschaft des
Dollars nun in Gefahr wird der ün seine
neue Alternative sein könnte es eine
Währung geben die Ampel Sam's
finanzielle Basis erschüttern wird
welche Folgen könnte dieser monetäre
Feldzug haben könnte er das Ende des
amerikanischen Imperiums einläuten
gehört die Zukunft den brexit-staaten
tja was würdet ihr dazu sagen wenn ich
behaupten würde dass die bricks mit
einer eigenen Währung den USA gerade zu
einem Gefallen erweisen würden ihr
glaubt mir nicht nun am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr nicht nur alle
Antworten auf diese Fragen Westen
sondern auch all jene Zusammenhänge
genau verstehen die in den meisten
Ideen geflissentlich übergangen werden
bevor wir doch richtig loslegen müssen
wir euch noch einen Tipp mit auf den Weg
geben wie ihr euer Wissen auch außerhalb
von visualpolitik pusten könnt
vielleicht fragt ihr euch ja manchmal
wie wir es schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören artikelanalysen
Videos Podcasts und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagen wissen das notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen und genau
dann ist man bei blinkist richtig denn
es verschafft einen nicht nur mehr Zeit
sondern motiviert auch noch durch eine
unterhaltsame Aufmachung ja und die
Berliner Firma blinkist hat mit ihrem
Beitrag nicht nur das heutige Video
möglich gemacht nein wir selbst nutzen
Ihre App auch um täglich unseren eigenen
Wissen Horizont zu erweitern blinkist
bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5000
Sachen Büchern und Podcast auf dein
Handy und dann erlebst du wirklich einen
ungeahnten wissensbrust anstatt Stunden
in die Lektüre kleines Buches zu stecken
und es dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende
zu lesen ziehst du dir in 0,nichts die
immer sehr angenehm und locker
geschriebene blinkist Version rein man
merkt sofort dass da echte Profis und
Talente am Werk sind stell dir vor wir
würden einen wertvolles aber langes Buch
in eine knackiges und leicht
verdauliches visualpolitik Video gießen
und genau das macht blinkist ein
Beispiel sind Bücher von Autoren mit
denen man vielleicht nicht immer einer
Meinung ist Moment aber kann man sein
Horizont besser erweitern als mit
Informationen die eben nicht aus der
eigenen Bubble stammen mir ist z.B das
Buch kein Kapitalismus ist auch keine
Lösung der ehemaligen Pass Autorin
Ulrike Hermann aufgefallen auch hier
habe ich mir gesagt hat ist ja nicht
gerade mein Leib und magenblatt Erzengel
auf Amazon haben das Buch auch dafür
kritisiert lang atme zu sein musste ich
mir das also wirklich antun andererseits
hat mich schon interessiert was da drin
steht und dank der Fesseln geschriebenen
Link ist was und konnte ich innerhalb
von nur 25 Minuten herausfinden dass
dieses Werk zumindest in der blinkist
Version meine Horizont durchaus bereiten
konnte solides Wissen dass ich ohne Bl
ist sicher verpasst hätte kurz gesagt
diese App wird mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch dein Leben
bereichern egal für welches Thema du
dich gerade interessierst die Auswahl
und der Spektrum sind wirklich riesig
von Finanzen über Wissenschaft Politik
Karriere bis zu den klassischen Ratgeber
Themen um sein Leben zu optimieren aber
man kann mit Blick ist nicht nur sich
selbst sondern auch seine Lieben
bereichern es hat nämlich vor kurzem
eine ganz neue Funktion namens blinkist
spaces eingeführt damit kannst du deine
lieblings mit deinen Freunden und
Kollegen teilen und diskutieren die in
einem Buchclub und das ist noch nicht
alles visualpolitik Zuschauer bekommen
über den Link in der Beschreibung nicht
nur zwei Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von
einer sondern um drei noch 25% Rabatt
also zöger nicht besorg dir jetzt gleich
die kostenlose 7 Tage Testversion über
den Link unter diesem Video und fangen
dann gleich damit an deinen Wissenschaft
zu bereichern und wenn du das erledigt
hast können wir sofort zur Beantwortung
der großen Frage streiten könnten die
bricks die Dollar Dominanz brechen
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach jahrelangen Spekulation scheint es
so als ob der chinesische Yen nun
durchaus Fortschritte macht um die
globale Dominanz des Dollars zu beenden
zum Beispiel hat sich der Anteil des
Jedi an globalen Finanzhandel seit dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine mehr
als verdoppelt warum nun vor allem weil
Russland in nutzt um die westlichen
Sanktion zu gehen setzt euch an es steht
außer Frage dass die Russen gezwungen
sind ihren Handel zu entdeularisieren
und auch zur enduroisieren es gibt
Anzeichen dafür dass insbesondere
Russland den die entstanden genutzt und
es ist auch klar dass die Chinesen und
andere nach Möglichkeiten suchen die
Nutzung des Handelsabkommen auszuweiten
ehemaliger Wirtschaftsexperte des US
Finanzministeriums und ehemaliger
Berater des US-Handelsministeriums um
euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben der
Handel zwischen Russland und China
überstieg im Jahr
2022.185 Milliarden Dollar und wird 2023
die 200 Milliarden Dollar macht
überschreiten und was ist das
Interessanteste an all denen nun
russische Unternehmen bezahlen die
meisten
chinesischen Importe bereits Indien und
das ist noch nicht alles der Jürgen
Handel an der Moskauer Börse ist in die
Höhe geschnellt und die von SWIFT
ausgeschlossenen Banken nutzen jetzt
Tipps das chinesische crossborder
interbank payment system und es gibt
noch mehr Vladimir Putin hat gesagt dass
er die chinesische Währung nicht nur für
den Handel mit China nutzen will sondern
auch als Zahlungsmittel für den
russischen Handel mit Asien Afrika und
Lateinamerika wie der stellvertretende
russische ministerpräsen Alexander Nowak
bestätigte wickelt Russland bereits mehr
Handelsgeschäfte in Hyänen als in Dollar
ab aber natürlich geht es nicht nur um
Russland dass er nicht gerade ein Land
ist mit dem es bergauf geht und das eine
große und aussichtsreiche Zukunft hätte
[Musik]
andere Länder wie Saudi Arabien
Bangladesch Indien Argentinien Pakistan
Irak und Bolivien haben begonnen oder
Schein kurz davor zu stehen mit China
direkt in die end zu handeln bzw
Verträge in der chinesischen Währung
abzuschließen Argentinien zahlt durch
chinesische Importe Innenstadt in Dollar
die argentinische Regierung hat am
Mittwoch angekündigt dass ich
chinesische Importe künstlich in die
entstanden in Dollar bezahlen wird um
die schwindenden Dollar Reserven des
Landes zu entlasten und ja es ist
möglich das wäre auch über einen großen
Teil des saudischen rohölhandel sprechen
was Schlagzeilen wie diese erklärt nun 9
dezember 2022 Chinas Ski fordert auf dem
Golf Gipfel in Riad einen Ölhandel in
Saudi-Arabien erwägt die Endstand Dollar
für chinesische ölkäufe zu akzeptieren
die Gespräche zwischen Riad und Peking
haben sich beschleunigt da die saudische
Unzufriedenheit mit Washington wächst
die schandherr-börse unterzeichnet ein
Abkommen mit der saudi-arabischen Börse
und cross-listings und Datenaustausch zu
erproben da sich die Beziehung zwischen
Peking und Riad verbessern in
ähnlicherweise kündigten China und
Brasilien am 29 März konkrete Pläne an
mit ihren eigenen Währungen zu arbeiten
und den US-Dollar an ihren handelsbörsen
aufzugeben außerdem wird Brasilien unter
dem neuen Präsidenten Luna das Silva
allen südamerikanischen Ländern erlauben
Handelsabkommen mit ihnen in Hühnen
abzuschließen der Linke hat leider Lula
hätte sich nicht deutlicher ausdrücken
können
jede Nacht frage ich mich warum alle
Länder ihren Handel auf den Dollar
stützen müssen
warum können wir nicht in unserer
eigenen Währung Handeln selbst ein
französisches Unternehmen wieder Öl und
Energiekonzern Total hat Ende März
seinen ersten flüssig erdgas-stil in
Hyänen abgeschlossen und zwar mit der
China national offshore all Corporation
der Vertrag und fasste 55 Tonnen LNG aus
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
apropos Emirate wie es scheint verwendet
Indien bei seinen Geschäften mit
Russland häufig emiratete
ihr seht also legt Zeichen der Zeit
scheinen klar zu sein wir stehen vor
einer Großoffensive um den Greenback zu
stürzen oder zumindest um seinen enormen
internationalen Einfluss zur reduzieren
String genommen haben wir sie doch mit
keinem besonders neuartigen Phänomen zu
tun in China versucht schon seit der
Finanzkrise 2008 den Julien zu
internationalisieren bereits Mitte 2017
erfolgte die Einführung des sogenannten
pedroiden für den Ölhandel zwischen
Russland und China was wir gerade
gesehen haben inzwischen auf den
Großteil des Handels zwischen diesen
beiden Ländern ausgeweitet wurde
allerdings hat diese Operation nun
tatsächlich neuen Schwung bekommen ihr
müsst nämlich verstehen dass China und
andere Länder um jeden Preis nach Wegen
suchen damit die USA keine Möglichkeit
haben ihre diesen Reserven einzufrieren
so wie sie es mit Russland getan haben
ebenso soll eine Situation vermieden
werden in der ihre Wirtschaft blockiert
wird indem sie durch die USA am Handeln
mit Dollar gehindert werden ganz genau
die Sanktion gegen Russland nach dessen
überall auf die Ukraine eine
regelrechter Schock für alle autoritären
und expansionistischen Potentaten und
Aggressoren ein regelrechter Weckruf der
dieses Thema wieder ganz oben auf ihre
Agenda gesetzt hat die Frage lautet also
kann der UN den Dollar wirklich
verdrängen oder zumindest mit ihm
konkurrieren werden die arabischen
Länder beschließen von Pedro Dollar zum
pedrogen zu wechseln wird ein neuer
offshory in Markt entstehen der nach dem
Vorbild des Euro-Dollar sind weltweit
mit dieser Währung handelt und
investiert oder werden die bricks gar
eine ganz neue Weltwährung erschaffen
wie es Brasiliens Präsident Luna Silva
Jungs genau das werden wir jetzt ganz
genau untersuchen aufgepasst
[Musik]
tollown
nach Ansicht von visualpolitik ist der
Dollar im internationalen Währungssystem
so wichtig dass er den wirtschaftlichen
Einfluss der USA im Vergleich dazu als
er unbedeutend erscheinen lässt ihr
glaubt mir nicht dann schaut euch
einfach mal diese Grafik an wie ihr seht
sind die Vereinigten Staaten zwar für
etwa 24 % des weltweiten BIP und etwa
15% des handelsverantwortlich das sind
anständige zahlen aber nichts im
Vergleich mit ihrer Landeswährung die
den Planeten wahrlich dominiert fast 60%
der Währungsreserven und die Hälfte
aller internationalen finanzierungs- und
Handelsgeschäfte werden in der
US-Währung abgewickelt wenn man heute
über globale Finanzen und Währungen
spricht ist es klar dass man um den
Greenback einfach nicht herumkommt und
ja es stimmt seit dem Jahr 2000 ist der
Anteil der internationalen
Währungsreserven die in Dollar gehalten
werden von etwa 70% auf weniger als 60%
gefallen das ist etwas worauf die
schwarzmale immer wieder ein spielen
wenn es um die Zukunft von Onkel Sam's
Scheinchen geht darüber hinaus weiß
China hist orisch eine niedrige
Inflation aus die Währung war insgesamt
recht stabil und angesichts der größte
chinesischen Wirtschaft und ihre
Erfolgsbilanz ist es nicht überraschend
dass der Anteil an Währungsreserven die
in chinesische Währung nominiert sind
stetig gewachsen ist ja aber an dieser
Stelle kommt der große Plot fest denn
all diese Daten haben einen gewaltigen
Haken
[Musik]
erstens muss man bedenken dass sich die
internationalen Reserven seitdem um den
Faktor 4 erhöht haben so dass die
absoluten Reserven in Dollar heute viel
höher liegen als sie je zuvor und
zweitens das von diesen Rückgang des
Dollar Marktanteils dem der chinesischen
Währung vor allem die Währungen Kanadas
Australiens Schwedens Südkoreas und
Singapurs profitiert haben und jetzt
haltet euch fest all diese Länder
unterhalten dollarkurslinien mit der
Federal Reserve das bedeutet dass diese
Staaten in der Praxis nicht nur enge
Verbündete der USA sind sondern dass
ihre Währungen auch fast vollständig mit
dem Dollar konvertierbar sind und genau
das ist der Grund weswegen viele
Institutionen kein Problem damit haben
sie zu verbinden hinter dem Erfolg
dieser Währungen steckt also wieder vor
allem der US-Dollar mit anderen Worten
die auch immer man es dreht und wendet
egal wie man es betrachtet die Dominanz
des green back bleibt überwältigend und
weit verbreitet er ist die wichtigste
internationale Währung und ja ich weiß
was viele von euch von mir hören wollen
dass ich das bald komplett ändern wird
dass die Chinesen den Amerikanern den
Rang ablaufen das Shanghai die Wall
Street schlagen wird nun so leid es mir
tut oder auch nicht es scheint eher
unwahrscheinlich dass dies eintreten
wird
angesichts der vorliegenden Daten
scheint der unh heute kein großes Risiko
für den Dollar darzustellen viele
Analysten gehen zwar davon aus dass der
Marktanteil des Viren in den kommenden
Jahren noch etwas wachsen wird quasi als
Nachwirkung des enormen
Wirtschaftswachstums das China in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten erlebt hat aber
wie gesagt er lebt hat die gegenwartung
Zukunft der wirtschaftlichen Bedeutung
Chinas sieht weniger rosig aus über die
vielen Gründe dafür haben wir bereits
mehrere Videos sowohl hier auf
visualpolitik als auch von unserem
schwesterkanal visual economic gedreht
und ich werde sie euch natürlich
verlinken das Ergebnis ist auf jeden
Fall klar im März 2023 machte der UN
trotz Jahre lang Bemühungen nur 2,4% der
internationalen Zahlungen aus die über
das Swiss System das weltweit führende
überweisungssystem abgewickelt worden
auf den Dollar in vielen dagegen mehr
als 40% aller Transaktionen aber lasst
uns doch um das Ganze noch ein wenig
besser zu verdeutlichen einen Blick auf
den Fall Südkorea werfen China ist
nämlich der mit Abstand größte
Handelspartner des Land
Sanktion angeht befindet sich dieser ja
auf der gleichen Seite wieder doller
[Musik]
daher betrachten wir Dollar und Euro in
diesem Video nicht als politischer
Rivalen beide Blöcke ziehen sozusagen am
gleichen Ende des Seils stehen für ein
und dieselbe Welt und Wirtschaftsordnung
auf wirtschaftlicher Seite sind die USA
und Europa natürlich Konkurrenten aber
das wird ein Thema für ein anderes Video
also Abo nicht vergessen unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um es nicht zu verpassen und
wenn wir schon dabei sind wagen wir noch
eine weitere Prognose trotz all dessen
was ich gerade gesagt habe gehen wir
davon aus dass wir in den nächsten
Jahren mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
beobachten können dass der Marktanteil
ist wie ein Welthandel noch etwas
wachsen wird ihr erinnert euch sicheren
Nachrichten wie diese der Anteil des an
der handelsfinanzierung hat sich seit
Beginn des Ukraine Kriegs verdoppelt
chinesische Kreditgeber gewähren
russischen Banken nach westlichen
Sanktionen Milliarden von Dollar die
Schritte von vier der größten
chinesischen Banken sind Teil der
Bemühungen Pekings den Mini als
Alternative Währung zum Dollar zu
fördern Chinas Engagement im russischen
Bankensektor sich in den 14 Monaten bis
Ende März dieses Jahres vervierfacht ja
auf den ersten Blick könnte man also
durchaus den Eindruck gewinnen dass die
globale Stellung des Dollars gefährdet
sein könnte wenn man dann jedoch ein
wenig unter die Oberfläche bzw hinter
die Kulissen blickt sie die Geschichte
schon wieder ganz anders aus es ist
nämlich die eine Sache mit einer Währung
Handel zu treiben und eine ganz andere
sein Geld in derselben Währung zu halten
und hier haben die USA ganz eindeutig
die Oberhand im Einzelnen können wir
drei große Vorteile hervorheben erstens
die Märkte
die amerikanische Supermarkt verfügt
über die größten liquidesten freisten
und gleichzeitig sichersten
Kapitalmärkte der Welt für ausländische
Investoren ist es sehr einfach ihre
Dollars doch zu platzieren um damit
Gewinne zu erzielen Aktien
Staatsanleihen und Fonds aller Art in
den USA könnt ihr praktisch so viele
Dollars einführen verschieben oder
herausnehmen wie ihr wollt ohne dass es
zu Problemen kommen könnte oder der
Markt zusammenbrechen er ist einfach zu
groß das ist etwas das in China einfach
nicht gegeben ist und wisst ihr was in
gewisser Weise erinnert uns das an den
Fall des Euro der Euro ist die Währung
eines gigantischen wirtschaftsblocks und
hat seit seiner Einführung erheblich an
internationaler Bedeutung gewonnen aber
eben nicht in genügendem Ausmaß um den
Dollar ernsthaft Paroli bieten zu können
ja der Euro hat eine extrem starke
Position im internationalen Handel aber
bei allen anderen Parametern ist diese
Währung viel kleiner als der greenbag
und falle hier das kommt noch ein
weiterer kritischer Faktor hinzu der
quasi eine Art Pille darstellt für alle
Kapitalisten denen ihr Hab und Gut lieb
ist und das sind so gut wie alle die
chinesischen Finanzmärkte sind nicht nur
viele kleiner nein für eine wirklich
harte Obergrenze sorgt vor allem das
enorme Risiko dass die pseudo
kommunistische Regierung in Peking aus
politischen Gründen ganz einfach mal
sagt der da oder die da passen uns nicht
lasst uns doch einfach mal ihre Vermögen
Beschlagnahmen oder gleich eine ganze
Branche zer zum Beispiel nicht von der
herrschenden klicke kontrolliert wird
ganz genau der ganz große Pferdefuß der
chinesischen Finanzmärkte ist die
grottenschlechte Rechtssicherheit wenn
nämlich im Falle des Dollars und des
Euros aufgrund des westlichen
sanktionspotentials alle töranten und
Potentaten um ihr in diesen Währungen
angelegtes Vermögen fürchten müssen zu
müssen umgekehrt alle er
rechtschaffenden und freiheitlich
orientierten Anleger und Situationen die
politische Willkür Pickings fürchten und
eines kann ich euch versichern deren
Gewalt Finanzkraft wird aufgrund der
positiven wirtschaftlichen Effekte einer
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
noch lange Zeit diese Welt dominieren
ich meine mal ehrlich womit würdet ihr
euch wohler fühlen mit Dollars in der
Tasche oder mit Vienna und ja diese
Präferenz gilt auch für Anleger in den
bricks-ländern wie Brasilien oder Indien
die gleiche Einstellung herrscht
natürlich auch in den arabischen Ländern
vor und daran ändert auch ihre Aufnahme
in den bricksclub nicht das Geringste
denn stell dir vor du bist ein Millionär
oder Milliardär in den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten oder der Manager
eines großen Fonds der die Vermögen
dieser Leute verwaltet ihre Profite
Maximilian und ihre Sicherheit
gewährleisten muss würde es dich
irgendwie jucken das ein paar
autoritären Politikern die Dominanz des
Dollars nicht passt weil sie ihre
politischen Ambitionen einschränkt und
sie liegen ihr nicht international
schalten und walten können wie es ihnen
passt wäre es überhaupt dein Job dich
irgendwie um diese Politiker zu schälen
ihnen bei ihren Plänen zu helfen nein
ganz und gar nicht dir geht es um nichts
anderes als die bestmögliche langfrist
Performance deiner Invest und welche
Währung würde in deiner Chancen
risikenbewertungsmatrix wohl besser
abschneiden nun ganz bestimmt nicht die
eines Landes wie China mit einer großen
zahlpolitisch motivierter
Kapitalkontrollen denn diese führen ja
schlicht und einfach dazu dass deine
finanziellen Ambitionen eingeschränkt
sind und du nicht frei mit deinem Geld
schalten und Spalten ist umtauschen und
aus dem Land bringen kannst ihr glaub
mir nicht nun eine der Gründe für diese
kapitalkontrolle liegt darin die
chinesischen Anleger selbst daran zu
hindern ihre Ersparnisse massenhaft aus
dem Land zu bringen genau das ist
nämlich zwischen 2014 und 2016 passiert
als die Bedingungen etwas gelockert
worden ganz genau sobald die Chinesen
selbst auch nur eine kleine Möglichkeit
bekamen ihr Geld in Sicherheit das heißt
aus dem hyän zu bringen hatten sie
nichts besseres zu tun als den Euro
Dollar zu stürmen ihr erinnert euch
nicht mehr nun hier eine kleine
Auffrischung eures Gedächtnis ist
Kapital Abflüsse aus China steigen 2015
auf schätzungsweise eine Billion Dollar
wohlgemerkt dies alles das geschah ohne
dass die Chinesen auch nur ahnen konnten
war es auf sie in Zukunft noch zukommen
würde nämlich die Gleichschaltung aller
Macht durch die Unterjochung Hongkongs
die exzessiven Null covid-lockdowns der
Feldzug gegen die Hightech Industrie und
den freien Bankensektor bevor all das
Los brach zog das Regime in Peking die
Zügel rechtzeitig wieder an 22 dezember
2017 China verschärft
Auslandsinvestitionen um Risiken zu
reduzieren hätten sie dies nämlich nicht
getan hätte der chinesische Kapital
Exodus 2014 bis 2016 wie ein
Kindergeburtstag ausgesehen gegenüber
dem was in den Folgejahren ab 2020
passiert wäre daher ist unser Urteil
glasklar es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich
dass der in eine echte Alternative sein
wird wenn es hart auf hart kommt es ist
nur schwer vorstellbar dass im globalen
Finanzsystem eine Währung eine zentrale
Rolle in ähnlicher Größenordnung wieder
Dollar spielen könnte wenn diese aus
einem Land kommt das viele
Beschränkungen für Inländer als auch vor
allem für Ausländer aufrecht erhält die
in China investieren oder mit
Finanzinstrumenten handeln wollen und
wenn man geopolitische Aspekte
berücksichtigt gehen wir davon aus dass
eben nicht nur die USA starke
internationale Präferenzen haben welche
Länder sie als Verbündete und welche sie
er als Herausforderer betrachten das
gleiche gilt nämlich noch viel mehr für
China und während die meisten von
Manager und Verwalter von
Währungsreserven nicht in Betracht
ziehen dass ihrem Geld irgendein
politisches Risiko droht wenn sie nicht
das tun was die Regierung der USA will
sieht es mit den Regime in Peking schon
ganz anders aus rechts und
Investitionssicherheit sind dort nach
wie vor quasi Fremdwörter im besten Fall
jedoch nur optional aber heißt das nun
das dem Dollar niemals eine starke
Konkurrenz erwachsen könnte nur nein
nichts könnte weiter von der Wahrheit
entfernt sein Hörzu
pranks die Mauer gegen den doller
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay nein es sieht also nicht so aus als
könnte der chinesische den Dollar
verdrängen er wird wahrscheinlich etwas
wichtiger und sichtbarer werden aber es
sieht nicht danach aus als wäre gerade
eher die beste Option um Uncle Sam zu
schlagen und wisst ihr was die Feinde
der USA wissen das bereits genau aus
diesem Grund haben sie eine ganz andere
Strategie im Sinn den großen Schachzug
der die bestehende Weltordnung
grundlegend verändern soll im März 2023
sagte der stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der staatsnummer der russischen
Abgeordnetenkammer Alex das Russland bei
der Entwicklung einer neuen Währung für
den grenzüberschreitenden handelsstaaten
eine Führungsrolle einnehmen würde und
auf dem brix-gipfel im August 2023 im
südafrikanischen Johannisberg wurde
diese Ideen noch mals von Brasilien
Präsident Lula das Silva Fossilien wir
reden hier nicht überleben Brasilien
Russland Indien China und Südafrika
machen immerhin mehr als 40% der
Weltbevölkerung und fast ein Drittel der
gesamten Weltwirtschaft aus
die Gruppe wird sich wie nun beschlossen
wurde sogar noch um Argentinien Ägypten
Äthiopien Iran Saudi-Arabien und die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate erweitern
und somit nicht nur um eine Billion
Dollar an BIP anwachsen sondern auch zu
einem wahren Rohstoff gegangen das Ganze
ist also wahrlich kein Witz keine
Randnotiz die man unter ferner liefen
abtun könnte denn was würde passieren
wenn diese Gruppe wirklich eine eigene
neue Währung einführen würde was wäre
wenn diese Währung dann zusätzlich mit
Gold und anderen wertvollen mitteilen
und Rohstoffen unterlegt und abgesichert
wäre
würde es dies einfacher und attraktiver
machen diese Währung als wäre auch
bewahrungsmittel zu nutzen nun genau das
scheint der springende Punkt dieser
Akteure zu sein und darüber hinaus sind
die bricks groß genug um andere Länder
in den Handel mit dieser neuen Währung
zu ziehen von Thailand bis Kasachstan
von halb Afrika bis Lateinamerika es
bedeutet nichts Geringeres als dass sie
leicht zu einer Währung werden könnte
die im internationalen Handel von
Ländern verwendet wird die 40 bis 50
Prozent des gesamten weltweiten BIP
ausmachen und nicht nur das da ihr Wert
durch reale Vermögenswerte gedeckt wäre
und es keine zentralen Kapitalkontrollen
durch ein bestimmtes Land gebe könnte
auch ein Finanzmarkt geschaffen werden
der es ermöglicht sie als Reserve
Währung oder Wert Aufbewahrungsmittel zu
nutzen so weit zumindest die Theorie
denn natürlich würde das nicht alle
Probleme lösen ganz im Gegenteil
Rohstoffpreise schwanken über die Jahre
mitunter sehr stark eine Währung die zu
stark an sie gekoppelt ist würde nicht
gerade zur Diversifizierung von
Portfolios beitragen die sowieso schon
von den Konjunkturzyklen in diesen
Ländern abhängen ein klassisches Problem
wenn man Währungen miteinander verbindet
wird als asymmetrischer Schock
bezeichnet von einem solchen spricht man
wenn bestimmte Ereignisse ein Land
diametral anders treffen als ein anderes
und im Allgemeinen sind flexibel
Wechselkurse ein gutes Mittel um diese
Schocks ab Federn wenn man sich nun die
bricks-staaten ansieht und die
Exporteure von Rohstoffen mit den
Exporteuren von Industriegütern
vergleicht fällt einem sofort auf dass
die Unterschiede extrem groß sind
zwischen diesen beiden Lagern tun sich
gigantische Gräben auf ein Beispiel ist
der Ölpreis wenn er steigt sind Russland
und Saudi-Arabien super glücklich aber
China und Indien und Südafrika als große
ölimporteure erleben dann einen Schock
einen klassischen asymmetrischen Schock
eben ihre Interessen sind exakt
gegensätzlich lassen sich jedoch durch
eine Anpassung von Wechselkursen
miteinander vereinbaren wenn diese
Länder unterschiedliche Währungen haben
mit anderen Worten wenn die Ölpreise
steigen steigt normalerweise der Rubel
und indische Rupie wertet ab damit
bekommt ihr indische Exportindustrie
eine Verschnaufpause mit einer
gemeinsamen Währung geht dies jedoch
nicht das sieht man häufig am Beispiel
des Euro dann müssen alternative
Instrumente wie z.B einen gemeinsamen
Finanzausgleich die Wechselkosten
Dynamik ersetzen hierzu ist jedoch ein
extrem hoher Grad an Operation und
Integration notwendig und was meint ihr
zu welchen Grad an politischer und
fiskalischer Integration werden all
diese bricks-staaten bereit sein ebenso
bleibt abzuwarten wer für diese Währung
zuständig sein wird ob eine
supranationale Zentralbank eingerichtet
wird und ob es überhaupt möglich ist bei
der Gestaltung einer einheitlichen
Währungspolitik so viele Staaten
zusammenzubringen die Transparenz und
die Einhaltung von Regeln ja nicht
gerade gewohnt sind gegenüber den bricks
erst recht den erweiterten ist z.B der
Euro Raum ein super homogenes idyl der
Einstimmigkeit und Ehrlichkeit und wir
alle wissen für welche Verwerfungen
bereits hier die im Vergleich
unbedeutend erscheinen Gegensätze der
Europäer immer wieder Sorgen ob sie nun
wirtschaftlicher politischer oder
struktureller Natur sind und jetzt
stellt euch mal vor dass ich der Akte
realisierende Jahr verfeindete Nationen
die Indien und China auf eine gemeinsame
Währungspolitik einigen sollen und dann
auch noch mit derartigen States wie
Russland Südafrika und euphieren die
Solid Edition Araber mit den
schiitischen Iranern das
hyperinflationsgeplagte Argentinien in
dem strenge Kapitalverkehrskontrollen
herrschen mit Saudi-Arabien das nur so
in Geld schwimmt und dessen Währung fest
an den Dollar gekoppelt ist die riesigen
Demokratien Brasilien und Indien in den
politischen kehrtwänden zum Wesen des
freiheitlichen pluralistischen Systems
gehören mit all den totalitären
Diktaturen autoritären Regimes und vor
allem Monarchien glaubt ihr wirklich
dass ein machthungriges
expansionistisches und
gleichgeschaltetes China bereit wäre
seine monetäres Souveränität mit anderen
Ländern zu teilen in seiner
Währungspolitik von neu-deli oder ja
abhängig zu sein ja genau genommen haben
diese Staaten eigentlich keinerlei
gemeinsame Werte wie sie zum Beispiel
die Europäer Teil gemeinsame Werte die
nicht nur helfen macht zu teilen sondern
mit deren Hilfe sie trotz aller Vielfalt
und Konkurrenz gerade in Notsituationen
immer wieder zueinander und zu
Stabilität finden können es sind gerade
diese Werte die für Verlässlichkeit
sorgen auf denen eine Währung
langfristig fusten muss die von einer
großen Masse an Investoren genutzt
werden will aber Moment mal ein
gemeinsamer wert wäre da doch wenn auch
es eher ein gemeinsames Interesse denn
ein Wert ist wovon ich hier spreche
natürlich die Abneigung gegen die
Dominanz der US Open und jetzt haltet
euch fest es wäre nämlich nicht einmal
nötig den Dollar zu besiegen wir könnten
sehr wohl Zeugen der Geburt eines neuen
multipolaren Währungssystems werden ohne
dass die Dollar Dominanz zusammenbricht
und Amerika deswegen gleich untergehen
würde das wichtigste Ziel der
Befürworter einer bricks Währung ist
nämlich erstmal nur zumindest einen
Ausgleich zu schaffen Alternativen die
Frage ist nur was würden die Vereinigten
Staaten dazu sagen sind sie besorgt über
diesen Schritt und werden Sie dies um
jeden Preis verhindern wollen ohne passt
jetzt mal gut auf wenn die Antwort wird
euch überraschen
[Musik]
das Ende der unipolaren hängemati
meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer es
ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass der Dollar
irgendwann einmal früher oder später an
Dominanz verlieren oder gar von einer
anderen Währung überholt werden wird
egal ob es sich um die berückswährung
oder eine andere handelt jede Ära geht
einmal zu Ende die Frage ist nur wann
irgendwann wird der Zeitpunkt kommen in
dem auch der US-Dollar auf einen
Konkurrenten treffen würde das Zeug dazu
hat ihn in den Schatten zu stellen mit
anderen Worten das was einst als Extra
bekanntes Privileg ist Dollars
bezeichnet wurde dann auf sein Ende zu
steuern außerdem ist es gut möglich dass
dieser Moment nicht mehr allzu weit
entfernt liegt der asiatische Boom hat
dazu geführt dass die US-Wirtschaft
einen immer geringeren Einfluss auf die
Weltwirtschaft hat von 40% des
weltweiten BIP in den 1960er Jahren auf
heute etwa nur 24 Prozent vergesst bitte
nicht das ist auch bei der Währung
durchaus auf die Größe ankommt damit der
Dollar die große Reservewährung bleibt
muss die US-Wirtschaft den Rest der Welt
mit immer mehr Dollar und immer mehr auf
Dollar lauten Vermögenswerten versorgen
doch es sind genau diese Operationen die
die Schulden der US-Regierung und das
chronische Handel des Landes finanzieren
anheizen und sogar fördern oder an
diesem Punkt gehen die Meinungen weit
auseinander
für einige ist es den USA gelungen den
Finanzsektor zu einem hyperproduktiven
Bereich der Wirtschaft zu machen dessen
Ausstoß fast schon Teil der
Handelsbilanz sein sollte mit anderen
Worten die Vereinigten Staaten
exportieren hochwertige Waren attraktive
Dienstleistungen und eben auch extrem
wertvolle Finanzprodukte Finanzprodukte
die ihrerseits die enorme technologische
Entwicklung des landesfinanziert haben
überlegt doch mal das vom Silicon Valley
und Seattle aus heute alles gelenkt wird
was mit Informationen Kommunikation und
Software zu tun hat das ausgerechnet
dort die profitabelsten Konzerne der
Welt entstanden sind basiert darauf dass
diese unglaublich viel Kapital zur
Verfügung hatten um ihre Technologie
viel schneller als alle anderen in der
ganzen Welt durchzusetzen ganz genau die
globale Dominanz der amerikanischen
IT-Industrie wäre ohne dass viele
billige Kapital dass Ihnen die ganze
Welt zur Verfügung gestellt hat kaum
möglich gewesen aber jetzt passt mal auf
denn das ist nur eine Seite der Medaille
andere Analysten sind in der enormen
Nachfrage nach us-finanzprodukten
nämlich einen gewaltigen Nachteil für
die Amis hä wieso das nun weil die
weltweite Nachfrage nach dem Dollar
seinen Wert höher macht als er
eigentlich sein sollte und dies stellt
einen großen Nachteil für die US
Exportwirtschaft da ihre Produkte werden
teurer die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
Industrie sinkt und es werden
Arbeitsplätze in der Industrie abgebaut
die zudem in der Regel sehr gut bezahlt
sind diese Theorie vertritt zum Beispiel
Jared burnsdeal und wer ist dieser Mann
nun kein geringerer als der Leiter des
Kanzel auf economic advisors der
Regierung beiden er ist quasi der Chef
Volkswirt des Weißen Hauses also nicht
irgendwer sondern jemand auf den der
Präsident hört
und seiner Sichtweise zu Folge würde die
Schöpfung einer weiteren wichtigen
Währung die Macht des Dollars keineswegs
erschüttern vor allem nicht in absoluten
Zahlen aber sie würde den starken
Aufwärtsdruck auf den Greenback mindern
dies könnte dann einige große
Ungleichgewichte wie das Handelsdefizit
verringern und die relative
Überbewertung eindämmen die nach Meinung
viele die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der US
Industrieunternehmen stark
beeinträchtigt dabei geht es natürlich
vor allem um jeden Branchen die im
Gegensatz zur Marschen starken
IT-Industrie über keine exorbitanten
Gewinnspannen verfügen also zum Beispiel
genau jene Unternehmen aus dem
rostgürtel und den zwingsteaks in denen
die Wähler eines Donald Trump Arbeiten
es geht um Bundesstaaten deren Wähler
bei der Wahl des Präsidenten Meisters
Zünglein an der Waage darstellen weder
Demokraten noch Republikaner können es
sich leisten diese Arbeitsplätze allzu
stark zu gefährden wie ihr seht besteht
also quer über das gesamte politische
Spektrum der USA einen Interesse an
einem schwächeren Dollar oder zumindest
daran dass er nicht doch weiter an Wert
gewinnt folglich ist man ein Washing
wenn es darauf ankommt vielleicht gar
nicht so besorgt darüber dass nicht
jeder auf der Welt so glücklich mit der
Dominanz des Dollars ist und mal etwas
dagegen unternehmen will das Problem
stellt also für alle sowohl die USA als
auch die bricks also eher darin zu
bestehen das esse ich um ein extrem
schweres Unterfangen handelt das bisher
niemanden wirklich gelingen will und was
die Märkte davon halten zeigte sich
ausgerechnet zu der Zeit als die bricks
mit großen Tamtam zum Sturm auf die
Dollar Bastion bliesen 20 August 2023
die endolarisierung gerät in eine
Vertrauenskrise da der UN der Rubel und
der argentinische Peso gleichzeitig
abstürzen die internationale Kampagne
zur Beendigung der Dominanz des
US-Dollars im Welthandel und bei
Investitionen gerät in eine
Glaubwürdigkeitskrise da die Währungen
ausgerechnet der Länder die die Bewegung
anführen einen schweren Schlag erleiden
allein in der vergangenen Woche stürzten
der chinesische Hyänen der russische
Rubel und der argentinische Peso
zeitgleich ab und zwangen Zentralbanken
diese Länder zu drastischen Maßnahmen um
die Märkte zu beruhigen die schlechte
Performance dieser Währungen kommt zu
einer Zeit in der alle drei Länder
versuchen sich vom US-Dollar zu lösen
was als entdollarisierungstrend
bezeichnet wird der jüngste Rückgang und
die Volatilität des chines des
russischen Rubels und in geringen Maße
auch des argentinischen Peso werden die
Idee der entlarisierung nur noch weiter
in Frage stellen die größte
Herausforderung ist jedoch eine interne
da sich die genannten Länder nicht auf
einen klaren Weg zur enddollarisierung
einigen können abgesehen von der
Steigerung des Handels in ihren eigenen
Währungen diese Tendenz hat in letzter
Zeit sogar noch weiter zugenommen obwohl
die Länder ihre wiesenreserven
diversifiziert haben und dennoch halten
die meisten von ihnen immer noch mehr
US-Dollar als in allen anderen Währungen
zusammengenommen aufgrund seines enormen
wirtschaftlichen Einflusses der
Finanzmärkte und er Rechtssicherheit
wird der Dollar also sicherlich eine
führende Währung bleiben aber welche
andere Währung wird ihnen begleiten nun
zunächst einmal scheint die Wohnung
beiden darüber nicht übermäßig besorgt
zu sein wie ihr gesehen habt ist sogar
das Gegenteil der Fall im Jahr vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl bippern die
Politiker in Washington vor einem
starken Dollar nicht vor einem schwachen
ihr versteht ihr sicherlich auch warum
es sowohl der Yen als auch eine
hypothetische bricks Währung extrem
schwer haben werden die Forderungen nach
einer gemeinsamen Währung ist eine
schnell in die Welt gerufene parole eine
Vision die erstmal unglaublich attraktiv
klingt wie wir doch gesehen haben
erfordert die Einführung einer echten
gemeinsamen Währung wie zum Beispiel des
Euro eine Menge Vorbereitung und viele
Gemeinsamkeiten zwischen den Staaten
unterm Strich kann man also sagen dass
es sowohl zur Zeit als auch in
absehbarer Zukunft einfach undenkbar ist
dass die brixländer ihre
währungsführerinität an eine gemeinsame
Institution eine gemeinsame Zentralbank
oder einen gemeinsamen währungs
Emittenten abgeben würden natürlich
könnten es die bridgestanden schaffen
ihre gewaltigen Unterschiede und
Differenzen auszuklammern indem sie so
etwas wie eine zwischenwährung schaffen
ohne die Souveränität über ihre
Landeswährungen aufzugeben tatsächlich
ist dies genau das Modell das von den
meisten Befürwortern einer bricks
Währung favorisiert und als am
wahrscheinlichsten angesehen wird dieses
Konstrukt wäre aber nichts weiter als
ein Währungskorb mit einem gewichteten
Durchschnitt all dieser
unterschiedlichen Währungen die nur
wenig gemein haben es würde sich nicht
wirklich um eine neue Währung handeln
nur um ein weiteres abstraktes
Finanzinstrument das von jeglicher
konkreten und verbindlichen währungs-
und Wirtschaftspolitik entkoppelt ist im
besten Fall würde es als eine Art Hilfe
als berechnungsmechanismus zur
Harmonisierung von Handelsaktivitäten
dienen dieser könnte durchaus eine
Nutzen haben aber niemand weiß wirklich
wie er auf jene asymmetrischen Schocks
reagieren würde die ich euch vorhin
erläutert habe es wäre extrem
herausfordern Finanzinstrumente und
Finanzprodukte aufzulegen die auf diesen
Mechanismus den nominiert sind und sie
dann an Investoren verkaufen zu wollen
die Frage lautet daher würdet ihr eure
Ersparnisse in diese bricks Währung
investieren wollen euer Geld einem von
China und Deutschland geführten Verbund
anvertrauen würden die USA von dieser
neuen alternativwährung eher profitieren
oder eher damit verlieren würde ein
weicherer Dollar der europäischen
Wirtschaft schaden könnte wirklich eine
Währung entstehen die in der Lage ist
die Macht des Dollars zu verdrängen wie
immer sind doch eure Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gebt uns bitte ein
Like heißt mit euren Freunden und
diskutiertes mit ihnen vergiss bitte
auch nicht das aber mit glücklich und
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]